bonsoir Paul saint-pierre-plamandon
bonsoir vous êtes dans le studio du
Figaro vous êtes donc à Paris vous êtes
en France vous êtes en Europe pourquoi
cette tournée
parce que notre vision du Québec qui est
un Québec qui rayonne qui existe et qui
rayonne partout à l'international et la
mission fondamentale du Parti québécois
et de faire du Québec un pays une
question qui reprend l'espace
indépendant
et une question qui dans l'espace
québécois reprend de la vigueur à la
lumière de phénomènes récents comme
notamment le déclin du français au
Québec le déclin du français dans toutes
les provinces canadiennes y compris le
Québec un déclin évidemment culturel qui
vient avec et donc de véritables
questions sur la capacité des
Québécoises et québécois de d'assurer
une pérennité au fait français en
Amérique comment on voit que le français
décline au Canada et au Québec on se fit
sur Statistique Canada qui ne sont pas
indépendantistes et qui nous disent que
le Français a perdu 5 points pourcentage
en quelques années et que le déclin
attendu du français au Québec est encore
plus important ce sont des données qui
sont confirmées lorsqu'on examine la
langue du travail la langue de la
consommation culturelle tous les
indicateurs nous disent que il souffle
un vent de mondialisation qui se produit
en anglais
et on a également un gouvernement
fédéral canadien qui somme tout assez
hostiles à reconnaître le besoin de
protéger sur le plan culturel comme
linguistique le français et donc
jadis les Québécoises du Québécois
avaient un sentiment de sécurité
l'assurance à travers notamment une loi
qui s'appelle la loi 101 que le français
était protégé
se pose maintenant la question de notre
capacité véritablement la offrir un
avenir aux Français et on pense que ça
passe par l'indépendance c'est-à-dire
décider par nous-mêmes quelles sont les
politiques adéquates sur le plan
linguistique et culturel mais on pense
que ça passe également par des relations
plus étroites avec la France parce que
la France joue un rôle essentiel crucial
dans le métier du de la vie culturelle
en français en Amérique mais vous pensez
que les Français croient encore en ça
est-ce que français les Français croient
encore à la nécessité que le français
soit fort et vigoureux c'est ce que je
suis venu me poser comme question et
quelles sont les réponses que vous avez
obtenues sur ça
parce qu'il y a plusieurs des mêmes
questions qui se posent en France est-ce
que la France qui est d'une richesse
culturelle qui est une nation tellement
grande sur le plan linguistique et
culturel est-ce qu'elle a elle se fonde
à l'impérialisme culturel
englo-américain ou est-ce que au
contraire on veut une France qui rayonne
sur le plan culturel au bénéfice du
Québec certes mais au bénéfice de la
France donc du point de vue de Québécois
les mêmes questions se posent en France
et évidemment qu'on encourage les
Français à prendre toute l'espace
possible pour la culture en français et
on dit aux Français avez-vous de
l'intérêt pour que le fait français en
Amérique continue la plupart des gens
nous répondent avec un grand sourire
parce qu'il y a une amitié Québec France
qui date il y a une diplomatie du Parti
québécois en France qui date de
plusieurs décennies et ses amitiés là
elles sont toujours là et je le sens
dans tous les partis politiques partout
au scolaire on va y revenir vous dites
l'indépendantisme reprendre la vigueur
pourtant quand on regarde les chiffres
vous avez été le premier parti du Québec
votre partie a été longtemps au pouvoir
aujourd'hui vont représenter plus que
15% des électeurs votre tour est passé
non aux dernières élections vous faites
15% je suis sympa aux dernières
élections c'est
14,61%. sur les 125 députés du Québec
tous les partis d'opposition ont obtenu
grosso modo 15% donc il y a eu plusieurs
parties de position et le parti
majoritaire
mais comme tout en politique il y a des
sites qui se terminent et ce qu'on voit
dans l'espace
public c'est la remise en question du
Québec dans le Canada dans la mesure où
non seulement on y voit pas d'avenir
linguistique et culturel mais également
on voit une dérive idéologique au Canada
une vision que Trudeau appelle la vision
postnationale qui a juste un truc d'eau
donc le premier ministre justice Trudeau
voit le Canada comme la coexistence de
communauté ethnoculturelles ou
religieuses mais sans
sans la vision universaliste qui la
version québécoise et qui est sûrement
héritée de la France dans une large
mesure parce que ce sont des points de
vue qui se ressemblent donc vous
comprenez que en étant seulement 2% de
francophones en Amérique et en voulant
défendre un modèle sociétal différent de
ce que les Anglais et les Américains
génèrent le comme une nouvelle idéologie
les dérives qui viennent avec on a tout
un défi dont vous voulez parler par
exemple du communautarisme et également
des idéologies qui s'y retrouvent notre
plan des livres une nouvelle idéologie
qui se veut très morale mais qui
lorsqu'on gratte
renforce des préjugés notamment les
préjugés vis-à-vis les Québécois donc on
serait classe
ouais il y a un mépris en fait la seule
communauté ethnoculturelle qu'on peut
mépriser publiquement au Canada à mon
avis ce sont les Québécois ou les
Canadiens français alors que la doctrine
officielle du c'est la tolérance
d'ailleurs Justin Trudeau vient de
nommer une commissaire pour lui
ils viennent nommer une commissaire dont
la mission est de lutter contre la haine
et l'islamophobie et quand on regarde
ces déclarations des dernières années
souvent est le démontré ouvertement son
mépris envers les Québécois et pour
autant il le garde il la garde en poste
donc il y a plusieurs défis c'est le
Québec demeure dans le Canada il y a peu
d'avenir parce que la différence
québécoise elle est non seulement mal
elle est mal perçue au Canada mais elle
n'est pas tolérée d'une certaine manière
sur le plan politique et on pense que
d'expliquer notre situation d'expliquer
notre mission de finalement obtenir
justice à la lumière de l'histoire
d'obtenir un rayonnement à
l'international de pouvoir faire nos
propres choix on pense qu'il y a des
gens qui ont de l'écoute pour ça en
Europe et c'est le cas vous êtes proche
du Parti socialiste vous êtes allés les
voir vous avez vu François Hollande
alors moi frappé quand je vous entends
je me dis mais qu'est-ce que un parti
journaliste indépendantistes à la forte
au programme social vous n'êtes pas un
parti conservateur vous allez être
commun avec un parti comme le PS qui est
un parti européiste qui a combattu la
souveraineté et qui est converti au
libéralisme et plus le plus plus le
mandat de François Hollande
est avancé plus il est devenu libéral
donc vraiment pas du tout sur les mêmes
sur les mêmes thématiques que les votes
qu'est-ce que vous avez encore à vous
dire une chose il y a une amitié puis
une collaboration de ce monde à notre
fondateur rené-l'évêque c'est pas du
tout un dialogue de sourd parce que les
politiques sociales socio-économiques du
Parti Québécois sont véritablement
sociales démocrate et en effet c'est
vrai puis ça fait en sorte notamment on
parle également aux républicains on
compare bien des gens une fois qu'on est
en France on a une composante des
tonnassions qui s'affirment en effet
d'un drapeau québécois qu'on veut voir
flotter partout dans le monde donc il y
a un aspect également de conception de
la société qui croit que l'État nation a
un avenir et donc on parle pendant qu'on
est passé le Parti socialiste un parti
européiste et le grand dessin de
François Mitterrand ça a été l'Europe de
Maastricht donc c'est un parti du
dépassement de la nation qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez avoir de comment avec le
Parti socialiste mais c'est ça on a en
commun plusieurs une volonté de réduire
les inégalités sociales on a on est
socialement démocrate mais on parle à
d'autres parties avec qui on a d'autres
points communs donc faut faut voir que
le contexte politique est différent d'un
pays à l'autre et ça amène des
juxtaposition qui sont pas les mêmes
mais évidemment lorsqu'on va à
l'essentiel à savoir croyez-vous que la
diversité culturelle que représente le
Québec dans le monde méritent de
survivre que pensez-vous de la
possibilité que le Québec finalement ça
ferme on obtient des réponses positives
tant au centre droit au centre gauche
est-ce que vous a dit sur ce plan là
François Hollande et Boris Vallot vous
avez rencontré sur quel point sur le
coin justement de la nécessité d'avoir
un Québec indépendant
c'est à dire que dans cette première
tournée parce qu'on veut réactiver la
diplomatie indépendante
on parle de notre situation puis on
répond aux questions quant à l'état de
la francophonie au Québec et quant à
l'état des relations Québec Canada
et donc notre but c'est pas d'obtenir
une un engagement ou une déclaration de
quiconque mais bel et bien de
sensibiliser
plusieurs Français qui aiment le Québec
au fait que le Québec a un avenir sombre
devant lui s'il demeure dans le Canada
et donc c'est une première étape
renforcer des coopérations des amitiés
qui sont importantes pour nous redonner
de la vigueur c'est ce que vous nous
dites depuis le début de cet entretien
Paul Saint-Pierre
l'idée d'indépendance du Québec n'est
pas mort c'est ce que disent d'ailleurs
nos excellents confrères du journal de
devoir mais les derniers sondages
montrent quand même que les partisans de
l'indépendance ont beau être en hausse
c'est moins de 4 sur 10 c'est 38% on est
moins on est loin du référendum des
milieux des années 90 patins parce que
les cycles qui ont mené au référendum
avaient des sondages similaires
donc quand on parle de 38%
d'indépendantistes lorsqu'on répartit
les indécis ça donne à peu près 42% et
le seuil d'une victoire c'est 50 donc en
fait on est dans des chiffres
relativement comparables à ce qui a mené
aux deux premiers référendum de
l'histoire de Québec par des échecs
la deuxième fois c'est
55 ans et on pense que c'est plutôt un
50% à 50% de non à l'indépendance qu'à
50% de oui à l'un des pas si on voit le
vert plein ou vide mais lorsque notre
survie linguistique lorsque notre survie
linguistique est culturel lorsque nous
intérêts économiques dépendent de la
réussite de ce projet-là et c'est mon
opinion je pense que c'est une absolue
nécessité pour le Québec bon travail
dans cette direction là en sachant que
on a quand même beaucoup avancé au fil
des décennies de vers ce projet-là
est-ce que l'indépendance du Québec le
Québec le fameux vive le Québec libre
1967 c'est pas un truc justement de 1967
un truc de vieux un truc de boomer non
en fait faut aller dans des écoles
secondaires ou des Cégep du Québec vous
avez recours pour voir vous avez perdu
mais il faut voir les vive des parties
vivre le Québec libre ça existe dans les
cégep aujourd'hui
du général de Gaulle est gravé au Québec
parce que une nation
au Québec nous dit on vous encourage
faut pas oublier que d'être conquis
militairement et d'être soumis à
l'Empire britannique pendant des siècles
c'est un effet sur notre confiance en
nous-même comme peuple lorsque les
Français nous encourage lorsque les
Français nous soutiennent dans notre
simple mission d'exister ça fait une
différence colossale pas juste de Gaulle
d'autres chefs d'État français ont joué
ce rôle là pour le Québec et je pense
que tous ces efforts un jour vont rendre
justice à cette quête qui est
parfaitement légitime est nécessaire
est-ce qu'il y a une place pour les
francophones en tout cas en Amérique
et qu'elle serait-elle
je pense que dans l'Amérique
tel qu'on la voit évoluer avec les
courants idéologiques très uniformisants
une forme d'impérialisme culturel
le Français a très peu d'espace il y a
peu de considération pour les
francophones ça vient avec du mépris
pour être très honnête donc si les
Québécoises et les Québécois n'arrivent
pas à s'affirmer
exister et aller chercher la
collaboration de leurs alliés l'avenir
est sombre par contre s'il réussit là où
malheureusement ils ont échoué dans les
essais précédent
je pense que c'est un avenir assez
radieux pour un Québec qui va montrer à
la phase du monde sa capacité d'innover
sa capacité à faire des choses utiles
cette différence finalement donc c'est
je préfère voir le vert plein que le
verre vide sur cette question là donc
c'est soit finalement Michael Collins
pour vous soit les Acadiens
je pense que on est on est rendu là au
Québec de dire
on réussit notre destin
ou on accepte notre déclin et un déclin
lent douloureux méprisant c'est ma
conclusion à ce statut notre histoire
vous vous êtes positionné à gauche comme
les nationalistes Gallois ou écossais
est-ce que le progressisme
glossaction
finalement ne vous condamne pas vous
éloigner de ces groupes là et à vos
droitisé
évidemment le néo progressisme considère
tout ce qui est à sa droite comme de
l'extrême droite
et je vois pas comment on va faire un
pays sans drapeau
[Musique]
donc si on veut faire naître un pays il
y a une base d'affirmation nationale
mais dans notre cas ça vient avec
beaucoup d'humanisme et une volonté de
réduire les inégalités sociales c'est
notre identité depuis notre fondation et
je pense qu'il y a un espace même si on
voit une polarisation à travers le monde
il y a un espace pour un discours
intelligent et porteur d'avenir
rapidement puisqu'il nous reste 30
secondes qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
dire à Emmanuel Macron
que le destin du français dans le monde
et particulièrement au Québec dépend
beaucoup de la capacité de la France de
la volonté de la France de faire
rayonner toute la richesse culturelle
française et que le Québec encourage
fortement la France à prendre sa place à
ne pas simplement s'insérer dans
l'impérialisme culturel anglo-américain
Macron c'est pas un Trudeau français
dans une analyse politique de la France
de mon rôle ici c'est de promouvoir le
Québec et surtout de faire la promotion
des amitiés France Québec je pense que
c'est sur mon rôle toujours positif télé
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon et il l'a
démontré encore ce soir merci beaucoup
d'avoir fait escale au Figaro pour cette
tournée française et cette tournée
européenne